foreign
student loans until I'm blue in the face
and you probably know that the Biden
Administration opened up a new loan
repayment plan it is called the save
plan it says this new repayment program
opens today for more than 20 million
student loan borrowers and these
payments are based on their income and
their family size okay the vitamin
Administration announced that the
savings on a valuable education program
that's the acronym I don't know do that
they just want something to sound good
so it's really just called the save plan
okay freaking bureaucrats that's all you
do they just want it to sound special
just know it's called the save plan okay
it's one of the many I should say one of
the four income driven repayment plans
this is the newest one because the the
program will calculate your monthly
payment like I said based on your income
your family size and the hope that
they're hoping is that it will help you
quote save money on payments now let's
stop right there
the way we teach I don't want you to
save money on payments I want you to pay
the thing off so I don't want your
payment to go lower necessarily I want
you to spend more money
monthly towards your debt so it can go
away faster right can I point out that
this is there's some Shenanigans in this
there are some Shenanigans this is this
is this is what you understand and don't
get sucked into this I'm just gonna I'm
gonna give it right back to you where
you were but I want to point out why
Jade's right
this program is an end around the
Supreme Court's decision the Supreme
Court said that Biden acted illegally in
trying to forgive student loans so what
does a Biden Administration do they come
up with this Nifty little program and
this is in the fine print
this program will calculate monthly
payments
based on borrowers income and family
size the administration estimates that
under this new save program more than a
million borrowers listen to this will
qualify for zero payments
zero dollars in payments it's an end
around this is what they're saying is to
Americans we feel your pain and they're
going we're going to try to fix it where
you don't have to pay anything back and
then they're going to go well based on
this uh some only will save about a
thousand dollars a year but this is all
about making sure that the interest
doesn't balloon but this is another
political tactic and if you go along
with this you're going to say thank you
Uncle Joe that you're never gonna pay
this off well here's the thing you know
and and I want to talk about this
practically because what I see on social
media is folks saying Jade why wouldn't
I do this the interest is not going to
accrue it doesn't matter what my payment
is at the end of this term no interest
will accrue and they'll forgive
whatever's left not gonna happen well
here's the thing no one is thinking
about how long this is okay you even if
you had it starts at nineteen thousand
dollars right if you have student loans
as low as nineteen thousand dollars
you're still in for a bare minimum of 10
years
you would have to pay a bare minimum of
10 years to get that proclaimed for
Freedom at the end and then for every
thousand dollars above that
another year okay so for most people
they're going to be looking just and
this is just averages all right most
people are going to be around 30 25 to
30 years paying back right that's not
worth it can I just let me let me tell
you guys a little story most of you guys
know that Sam and I had uh around 280
000 of student loans and a lot of hours
were private loans okay so we didn't
have all these options they were not
talking about repayment okay uh this was
back during the Great Recession that we
started paying our loans off Ken so you
know the world was going crazy very
similar to how it is right now now it's
inflation back then it was the housing
market gas prices all that crazy stuff
and
let me tell you my husband and I there
were different types of payment plans
back then and we hopped on a couple
because it was like okay our student
loans are so expensive we could not
handle them like we could not pay them
uh we didn't have enough money and I can
tell you even when you go on a payment
plan and it lowers your payment from 500
to 84 you still feel the weight you
still know those loans are there they're
sitting there they're waiting for you I
cannot physically imagine having that
there for the for the next 25 years you
want to talk about cutting years off
your life the stress the amount of
stress just knowing they were there now
here's what I do want to say because I'm
about to flip the script on some of
y'all
when it comes to these income driven
repayment plans the only time and I say
only in big red bold letters with lots
of exclamation points next to it okay
the only time I would ever consider a
payment plan like this is with the
intention of lowering my monthly payment
temporarily Ken so that I can get as
much money in my budget to throw it at
the smallest debt in my debt snowball
sure you got it do you hear y'all feel
what I'm saying I wrote it down in case
I forget if you're in trouble okay I
don't want nobody get out there if you
sign up for one of these income driven
repayment plans just simply to Kick the
Can down the road thinking you're going
to get forgiveness after 25 years y'all
need to stop right now you're just
playing yourself but if you really want
to play it right what you need to do is
like okay if my payment matter of fact I
have actually a picture of one of
salmonized payments that we had this was
from is this navient this is just one
set of the many loans we had you can see
there the payment is somewhere around
500 and some odd dollars and we are able
to work with them to get the payment
down to 257 dollars and we did that to
free up more money to go to our smallest
debt on our debt snowball we did that
temporarily and then when it came time
to pay that debt we were hitting that
thing with a machine gun as quickly as
we could so there is there is some smart
guidance around this Ken but what I
really don't want people doing is saying
oh great I can pay zero dollars I'll
just ride that way forever that's right
terrible idea yeah because here's the
deal you don't know what
administration's coming in next and
who's going to be in charge and this
idea that someone from the government is
eventually going to agree with this
person folks I mean you don't have
control over that no anything uh I don't
like that idea of holding it and holding
it holding it and holding it and think
about it these are the people
who helped put you in this position the
government cannot put you first guys
it's true they have never put you first
it's impossible for them to put you
first there's too many of us they're
gonna do what's best for whatever
Administration is at the time only you
can put you first well let's remember
that there's been no conversation in
Washington DC about stopping the federal
student loan that's a fact no he's so
while all these people are supposedly
being forgiven or hoped to be forgiven
they're still Doling them out to this
new fresh crop high school students that
are about ready to go into the next year
and yeah and so you've got to understand
folks this is a game that you haven't
set the rules for that's right you
either play the game or get out of the
game and we're here to help you get out
of the game I know that's right and
we're doing that we are doing a student
loan this is awesome live stream guys
this is what we need to be telling you
about you and Dave Ramsey Rachel Cruz
teaming up that's right September 12th
it's free is it it's free it's
absolutely free yeah guys we are going
to walk you through because I know y'all
half the folks can are like stop talking
and just tell me what to do tell me what
tell me what I'm supposed to do we are
going to tell you exactly what to do
matter of fact I was in a meeting
yesterday with the big eagle himself
uh-oh Dave Ramsey and he was like I'm a
big eagle as opposed to the bald eagle I
see the big eagle man he was like I
don't want to spend a lot of time with
any fluff I want to get down to business
these people want to know it yeah and
that's what we're gonna do guys sign up
we want to just you know save your seed
it's a live stream we want to know that
you're coming so sign up it's no uh it's
September 12th you can go to
ramsaysolutions.com student loans and
while you're there there's also some
things that you can start doing today to
start preparing for these payments
because they're coming back Ken they're
coming and listen to Vengeance I want
you folks to post this if you're a part
of our tribe and you you want to help
others you have a lot of power on social
media post the link ramseysolutions.com
student loans it'll bring up a really
cool graphic make you look like you know
what you're doing in social media tell
people it's free even if you don't have
loans you know someone who has students
be great I love it this is what it's all
about guys we want to bring that hope
it's not hopeless please please believe
me if I'm standing here with zero
dollars of student loan debt so can you
the time is gonna pass anyway most
people are able to do it in 24 36 months
we see it every day